i think that what you're doing with that
character is
is really fantastic you talk about how
um magic is genderless and i think
that's such a beautiful thing for kids
when i was
offered the role um and they kept saying
fairy godmother
fairy godmother you know i was like well
is it
is what it am i going to be a drag queen
am i in there like no we want you to be
who you are you know how you present in
the world
what you bring to it as
a voice for the lgbtq
plus community and the gender
non-binaries and the dems
in the days it's a new conversation and
we
um have to talk about it in a different
way and this
me in this role really pushes that
conversation forward audiences will have
to wait to see billy transform as
production on the live-action film
along with season three of his
critically acclaimed series pose
was shut down due to the global health
crisis i'd heard somewhere
where you said you were really taking
this time right now
um to reset yeah i just
you know the last couple of years of my
life
you know have been remarkable i always
explain it like
i'm indiana jones and that boulder is
behind me rolling behind me and i'm
running it
out you know to outrun it there was a
little bit of that going on
for me i just needed to be still
you know and the stillness has afforded
me
the space to um
begin to understand self-care uh
begin and boundaries balance
something that i've never really had
before i get it some people try to
figure out if they like themselves at
this point
right exactly right are you falling back
in love with yourself or where are you
at with that i'm trying
therapy wise and you know i'm getting
there
right i'm getting there you're also
giving out words with a song
for what it's worth
tell us a little bit about why you
wanted to put this song out to the
universe right now
activism is in my dna
[Music]
and i wanted to make sure that with the
new found platform that i have
that i was using my voice to speak truth
to power and to
hopefully ignite a generation
to remember that it's we the people
who rise up and make a change